I was just about a year ago that Yahoo
purchased tumblr there was a headline
just recently that said no regrets after
a year just between us really really I
mean look they they made an incredibly
compelling case a year ago Marissa and
her team spent a lot of time with us in
New York this was a chance for us to
have a conversation with somebody who
could bring a bit more to the table than
just writing a check and look they were
real believers in this path that we were
on and you know determined to help us
get there even faster in any ways that
they could help in a big first example
of that was the ad tech that powers all
of the targeting all of the analytics
and a whole lot more of the the ad
capabilities that were going to be
shipping this year
that's all powered by Yahoo now do you
have a one or two-sentence mission our
purpose in the world everything that we
started this thing for and everything
that we try and do always comes back to
empowering creators to make their best
work and get it in front of an audience
they deserve and we put the tools out
there into the world and we don't really
prescribe how people are gonna use them
we just try and stretch the canvas a
little bit we try and up the the jiff
limit so people can post longer loops we
support high res panoramas or photo sets
or just last week we added the ability
to customize how your blog looks on the
small rectangle which you know
traditionally there hasn't been HTML in
the small screen and the way that there
was on the big desktop webs we ship
those tools and then we're just
surprised thousands and thousands of
times over by what people do with them
it's this unbelievably fulfilling
mission and it's one that I think is
really underserved in this technology
industry that we're in today I just I
don't think if you look at any of the
other big networks right now Google or
Facebook or Twitter even Apple today is
really particularly concerned with the
creative community the people that
actually make the stuff that we enjoy
they're they're obsessed with social
they're obsessed with communication
they're obsessed with discovery but not
actually empowering the people that make
the stuff that we all like to talk about
I mean we're coming out of a world that
was made up of HTML pages that could be
anything and I've now been squeezed into
you know white profile pages on Facebook
and are now being squeezed into square
photos and six-second videos it's just
really ashamed to me to think that we're
telling those aspiring and talented
creators like make it square
make it six seconds that's that very
engineer's rule the world mentality that
i think under serves that creative
community some people like look back and
they said boy it was like my space my
space have these like allow these
messier personal spaces there and you
know can people around the book of away
to them because like they were so ugly
generally and so the big setback from my
space was actually that all that
customization was hacked in there it
wasn't actually supported by the
platform which meant that his people
were like hack in there their MySpace
pages apart they were breaking a lot of
functionality along the way and that
meant that myspace wasn't in a position
to change anything because it would
cause all that customization to break it
was all hacked in there at the same time
though people cherished their MySpace
pages they were meticulous about
customizing those things and I think
we've brought even more customization
into Tumblr while solving all of the
issues that you know we're to the
detriment of previous platforms like geo
cities are myspace and I think rather
than trying to work through those issues
the general course that the rest of the
industry took was like let's just
abolish it let's give everybody a
vanilla white profile page I think it's
giving up a lot may be useful when
you're trying to make something that
isn't just about keeping up to date with
people but when it really comes to
expression and empowering creators to
make stuff that we love and make stuff
that surprises us I think it's a real
detriment to that community